is
okay.
[Silence]
American.
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
discussing the narration of Abdullahb
Abbas
regarding the story of the
reconstruction of the Kaa. This is the
most major reconstruction of the Kaa all
the way until the time of our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. The Kaa was then
reconstructed again before he was made a
prophet. He was in his late 20s
and then it was reconstructed again in
the time of Abdullah
and then reconstructed again after his
martyrdom
and then after that it remains with us
today as it is.
We arrived at the
part of the narration where Ibraim
came to visit his son and he found him
out of the house and he met his first
wife and he asked her about their living
status, their situation and she said
complaining to him that they were living
in a very difficult situation and she
was discontented and unhappy. And so
Ibraimisam
told her to tell is when he returns to
change the threshold of his home. And
what he understood this to be was a
command from his father Ibraim to
divorce his wife and to take another.
Now I want to mention something because
I think a lot of people that actually
read this narration, have heard this
narration
are
unclear about
Ibraimis
took is
and his mother Haj to
Mecca
and he left them there as is mentioned
in this narration when is a little baby
he was still suckling
and when he returns here we see that is
grown his mother has passed away and he
is married
but this doesn't mean that Ibraim never
saw them again since that day he left
them there no he used to visit regularly
as a matter of fact there's an irration
that is mentioned by
inat
reported by
on the authority of
that
used to visit monthly on
the same bak that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam rode to
from Mecca to Alas
and he used to ride alak every month and
go visit isam
and visit his mother take care of them
whatever they need and come back and so
when I
was commanded to sacrifice his son is
it was during this time it was on one of
these many visits. So it's not to mean
that Ibraim
never saw his son again until he was
grown. There is no implication of that
in this narration or any other.
And so
is
he obeyed his father the of Allah and he
divorced his wife and he married another
[Silence]
for
So
in this the prophet Sam
tells us that
Ibraim
then came back after Ismael had
remarried
and again he came to visit and he found
his son was out of the house and so he
sat with his new wife and he asked her
about their living situation how are you
living and so forth she said we are
living in the blessings of Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and we are in sah and we are we are
living comfortably by Allah's blessing
and grace and she praised Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala for the things that
she had. So the first wife could only
see the half
empty part of the glass. The second wife
he married was focused on the half full
part of the glass. And this is what is
appropriate for isam.
This is what is appropriate for the
daughter-in-law of the khal of Allah the
daughter-in-law
and the wife of the messenger of Allah
who is the son of the messenger of
Allah. And so he asked her what is your
main food that you guys eat? and she
said water and meat. It was a lot of
hunting because again remember Jon were
archers and they were hunters and the
majority of their food and sustenance
was what they could hunt and so it
was meat. And so Ibraimisam
made dua for their meat and their water.
He said, "Oh, oh Allah, please place
blessing in their meat and in their
water." And this blessing and this dua
is seen all the way until today from the
dua of Ibraim that the meat in Mecca and
the water of Mecca are blessed by the
dua of Ibraim.
And the prophet sallallah.aii Wasam
tells us that they were they did not
have grains to eat at that time, rice
and wheat and so forth. And if they did,
he would have made dua for that as well.
for
him.
And
foreign.
[Silence]
And so
is as what happened with the first wife,
Ibraim
left and is
returned to the home. He said to his
wife, "Did anybody come looking for me
today? Anything happen while I was
gone?" She said, "Yes." As a matter of
fact, a very wellput together older man
came looking for you today. He said,
"Did he ask you anything?" She said,
"Yes, he asked me about our living
situation." And I told him such and
such. And I praised Allah and told him
that we are living in the grace of Allah
and living comfortably by Allah's mercy.
He said, "Did he tell you to say
anything to me?" He said, "Yes, tell him
tell your husband." He said to tell you
to convey a salam on his behalf and to
keep your home's threshold. Don't change
it. He said that is my father and you
are the threshold he has commanded me to
keep and he has commanded me to retain
you as my wife. And so then we have a
third time Ibraimis
returns and this time he finds is he
finds is with his back on thea leaning
on thea sharpening one of his arrows and
the narration will pick up from there
inshallah
Subhanahu
[Silence]
everything good.